[Music]
have you guys
heard of a thing called animal role play
i guess i could figure it out like you
put it you put on a cat outfit and [ __ ]
yeah i guess so yeah yeah or they just
pretend to be an animal
more of that more than that yeah so it's
not like a sexual thing
it can be it's so happy yeah
yeah how does that happen like oh i'm
i'm your dog and i'm sitting on the
couch right now you're gonna spank me
because i've been bad like that
or maybe they start off with like like
purring like
wait wait wait i just have to say go on
instagram and go on the hashtag
um horse girl is it horse girl oh yeah
we
talked yeah she like gallops yeah right
yeah
that's wild she's actually pretty
majestic she's really good yeah
she's been doing it since she was like
six or something she was really really
interested
how do you as a six-year-old identify as
a horse
like it's it's become more than just
like being a six-year-old pretending
like you're an animal like most kids
might do but to the point where now
you're uh like how old is she maybe like
a teenager
yeah she's like 16 or so i feel like i'd
have a daughter like that
we did too we've named her already
remember paperclip
you named her you named his daughter
what paperclip
like the little paperclip that would
come out that was their creation
not me i wasn't involved i would have
named her potato or something better
potato is better than me i like that too
anyways
animal role play is is a form of role
play where at least one particip
participant plays the part of a
non-human animal as with most forms of
role play it uses
uh it includes play and psycho drama
so i guess it's not necessarily sexual
but yeah you're literally acting out the
part of an animal
and then you have a pet owner like a cow
okay yeah and this is not sexual
i mean it definitely lends itself to be
more sexual and i'm gonna show you some
what kind of reminds me of like when you
play house as a kid you know and then
like you're like oh i'll be the dog
yeah you just go around barking yeah and
then someone has a leash and they're
walking you yep
yeah i like playing the dog
or the brother those were my two
favorite roles happening all right so
pretty sexual this is a story of a woman
who's 21 years old in austin texas who's
decided to quit her job to become a dog
to become a dog
she makes imagine how much money she
makes
yes a hundred thousand dollars a year or
a year figures yeah
six figures easily and this is her life
but why is her friend in a bikini
who's paying her yeah how is she making
money through
only fans no but like so she's
pretending to be an
animal and videoing herself of
pretending to be an animal and this is
how she's making money
and people buy videos of her being
a dog if a girl's on all fours people
are going to buy
that there's something innately sexual
about about a girl being
on all fours for sure what if she was
like a penguin then it wouldn't work it
probably won't be as hot
true i think but if you get naked and
you pretend to be [ __ ] whatever
animal
that's true you're pretty hot probably
make a decent amount of money true
but i'm about to show you some non-naked
stuff
and this is what she does really good
stuff uh she says she has
on her only fans she has naked stuff
well on tick tock she releases the
the the safe for work stuff and this is
the safe for work stuff here we go
[Music]
wow we should get it with her mouth what
kind of dog is that
oh yeah that's what she cheated no wait
she's actually eaten
sit oh it's helisexual dude
sit pretty bang
she's better than my dog yeah girl
yeah i don't know if she actually ate it
she's pretending to eat it
she's so slow oh yeah she wants you to
look at her butt
she couldn't get the balls
that's a big old booty it's hella
sexualized
i want to pick the you know better than
that
bad girl go to your bed
yoga pants no quit whining that crawl
too
oh my gosh she's arching her butt on
dude this is
homosexualized
hey give me the ball she moves quick
though
imagine explaining this situation to
like a world
what is happening right now so he risked
his life
to save this country so the future can
do [ __ ] like this or even
it's try explaining this to your parents
when you try to bring her home for the
first time oh this is my girlfriend this
is her job
and her dad's like oh cool what are you
doing well let me just show you some
videos so you can yeah it
explains itself there's like a ball
involved in the parents like oh okay
cool what do you do and you're like well
i can sit
i can
what i keep thinking though is like her
knees must be
hurting like she it doesn't seem like
she's wearing any knee pads i'm like
that's awesome
that's why they choose softer grinders
they chose the grass area to do all the
stuff
hurts my knees hurt true yeah for sure
but yeah you asked on why she didn't
choose a cat
dog so within this animal roleplay world
uh apparently most women choose to be
cats
dogs are meant for the men and it's
usually
gay men so like usually gay men are
involved with the animal role play
so she's like breaking barriers exactly
and she was like you know her
you know what there's there's the demand
for girls uh
for for people wanting to be dogs that
are girls
i'm gonna fill that void and she's now
making six figures
you know what hasn't been done yet
giraffe this is for free
dinosaur i'm pretty sure
that happens a lot especially with the
inflammation how's that sexual oh okay
okay
oh i see it i see it it's not supposed
to be sexual it's just
oh you definitely practice that in front
of a mirror
nah this is natural dyna inner dinosaur
dinosaur
he's a professional actor okay but let
me ask you a question yeah yeah go for
it
if okay so if she wasn't making a six
figure income doing this somehow
would she still do it is she doing this
because she genuinely enjoys it
like what about that one like she's
passionate about being a dog
you're saying if like if she's
passionate about being a dog or not yeah
it's just something that she genuinely
likes to do
yes that she has said that all her life
growing up she's always wanted to be a
dog
so like how you were saying growing up
some kids just you know
they play as animals and stuff so she
always chose to be a dog as a kid
and now that she's found this whole
community she's able to actually
bring her childhood dream she's good to
to be in her career now
are there anybody that's like i've
always wanted to be a bird
but then the first video they make they
jump off the wall they just laugh
probably i just hope they're not trying
to sit on your shoulder and then take a
[ __ ] oh god they're on the telephone
line and they just [ __ ] on you
you walk out there's a human poop on
your car
on your windshield you're like sorry i
was burdened
i was burning they go hang gliding and
then they just take a dump while they're
riding it yeah
dude that's what birds [ __ ] do damn
don't trust the bird but they
birds don't do it with like a negative
intention they don't do it knowing that
they're gonna ruin like
some of them do but like if you're a
human being and you do that you're doing
it
definitely knowing that you're going to
ruin someone's day yeah right
not unless you're in bird bird brain
mode
then you're like if someone's paying me
to be a bird i'm not the i don't have
bad intentions either i'm just trying to
be the bird there was a guy that
um he wanted to be a lizard really bad
and he tattooed himself his tongue's all
split and his eyeballs are all like
completely blue
that's a cat lady too yeah they're
dedicated wow that's awesome they should
go into this too then yeah but i feel
like those guys are the hardcore ones
and they judge people like her
she's just like she's not a real dog and
there's someone out there in a real dog
outfit every single day and they're like
we're the real dogs
like i even got my ears chipped yep like
a real dog
i'm neutered food
like there's gotta be like levels to
this [ __ ] because they're looking at her
as like this mainstream like
you're just selling your sexual like
fantasies to people
like we're the real dogs and there's
like a whole community of
like dog humans yeah like you just got
you just got empty ball sacks yeah
it's just squishy
neutered [ __ ] they went all in
because you know how like in every art
form there's that right there's like the
hardcore ones that don't get any respect
yeah and they don't really get the views
and [ __ ] and then the ones that like
just in the middle they go viral and
[ __ ] that's
true that's true yeah so for her she
says the more kinky the videos
the more they cost the number like the
most she's ever made on one single video
is a thousand two hundred dollars
wow on one video one video and then the
length of them are just roughly that
long too
just one of those little videos a
thousand two hundred dollars has anyone
explored
a fans only account no i don't even know
what it looks like because i'm curious
like how do they
know like is there like a preview of
what they're about to purchase or is it
like a subscription
they're using tick tock to promote their
fan only fan
no but i'm saying because you're you're
just talking about specifically one
video
she made that much money so then i'm
like there's actually some sort of like
sharing or like how does i know i know
someone that
that's her main income i i haven't even
asked like
what what it looks like behind the
scenes like how do you protect your
content from being spread right oh yeah
that's the idea right because then like
people can just upload your content that
they paid for
and now it's free for everyone else
everyone else to see
because i don't know i did hear though
that twitter
is a pretty good way of them getting it
because in twitter
they don't censor like anything
that makes sense yeah you can literally
like give head
and that can you could that could be
retweeted why there's porn on twitter
yeah oh [ __ ] and then that's how a lot
of the girls get
um viral i guess or like free content
and then from there
they joined their uh only fans or
whatever smart
yeah what i've been seeing a lot too is
on dating apps
um they'll try to trap for snaps
so like on dating apps you're like
thinking that someone likes you or
whatever right
there's like a lot of girls on there
just just like oh yeah like
uh sign up to my premium snap or
whatever and then
that's how they're finding customers
it's crazy
yeah hustlers yeah yeah and then just in
this video
uh there's one thing that she does not
do
uh as a dog and that is to play with
real dogs
that's something that's completely off
limits for because she gets a lot of
requests for that
oh stuff
yeah i don't i don't i don't i don't
know how sexual her content is on the
only fan stuff
but she does not maybe she doesn't even
want to like cross the line the first
video she's playing fetch with another
dog yeah there are other dogs what is
she talking about
she just means sexually sexual maybe
sexual then i don't know yeah yeah they
keep it very
like kind of they don't they don't look
like a dog
i thought the other dogs were just
extras
[Laughter]
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos
and i know it's been a million years in
the making but we finally got
just kidding news merch yep so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can run around yeah
jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you